you think you have a good radar for like
when something's off with a person oh
yeah I think so yeah where is it the
eyeballs are the shoulders well I think
it's mostly it's a lot of
overcompensation if somebody's real hard
swinging one way then something's going
on the other way right look at Cosby
yeah pull your pants up uh put on a
sweater don't curse and then he's
knocking chicks out then you got Ellen
who's like I'm all fun and games I dance
I hug everybody cutesy Tootsie and then
she's you know the biggest [__] on the
planet backstage we were lucky enough to
do that show best run show I've ever
been on well of course she's a [__]
Nazi regime over there yeah this is
no like David tell I I've never met him
but I heard he's like the sweetest guy
latest guy gives gifts to the staff
tip's huge yeah so nice to younger
Comics but yet his act is filthy so yeah
you know because we always talk about
Cosby but there's the other way too like
some like Jeselnik he's very dark on
stage but he's a nice guy clinka I mean
Seinfeld runs a cockfighting ring